hello and welcome to this video with a
wrong number
and I should fix it let's fix it and see
what tom - 1 6 5 is up - let's do
something else and let's mix it up what
do I play the action taken 96 it's been
ages since I looked at this absolutely
ages
yeah there's Queenie - and the caption I
have six mostly d3 yeah cause possible
it's possible but for d5 what is that
too much it's a desirable continuation
could could be too much oh that's I
don't quite believe in that this is so
critical so if I go deep before you know
okay Bishop d7 it's not a great idea but
a 6v6
just force this a little bit okay I
can't be should be 6f3 maybe this is
this is very much possible that I'm too
slow yeah at five and five is not not a
bad line but it's not not a line that
you should it's difficult to play let's
say on an on and off basis you really
have to know stuff and like I said here
let's try something it's this is this is
dangerous oh it's playing a bit playing
with fire and a little bit Wow Mikey
looks terrible if I take it
no still not really you don't see
anything else
very scary very scary position yeah just
be sure before maybe coming but okay I
can do this you should be for Queen g5
it's maybe not a problem
and now if I Castle long you can take a
6v castling longest
strong medicine counseling law again
somehow if I can play Bishop t5 against
Queen
we'd be okay but how how don't see how
Queen takes Bishop e5 is OK ROCK d1 King
CH
still cannot take bishop 35 is yes okay
he can take I can take going through
them
ready for OPH
okay ain't cannot move the Queen with a
chick
Queen somewhere see two can check me on
b3 there that's him threatening mage now
there is no rooty - what okay
I'm threatening mate maybe maybe this
position was okay at the end but that
looked very very questionable yeah d3 d5
the engine wants to take with the horn
or queen takes us also okay
maybe a six is too slow I was thinking
about Bishop t6 but I am worse a little
bit uncertain if this would work
Oh castling is a strong enough of course
yeah that's strong threatening made and
then I can take next okay six no
development development no I actually
can't cancel it's weird that I didn't
didn't think of that because of Kwan I
can just take here a couple of times and
here I'm fine
pretty much regardless I'm also fine if
I just take it okay so this is really
not what I should have done if T's looks
correct
three we should be six I didn't feel a
bishop t4 is so critical hmm the engine
he likes white this is not a surprise
but I was actually thinking I could be
an even deeper trouble service relative
the best move 51 Casey yeah I kept
things somewhat playable now I just have
to prevent them made of course route d2
is not possible I thought okay Queen g3
is not very threatening would have to
yeah this one probably five okay
mm okay yeah it's probably correct
yeah I'm worth of course may-maybe I'm
not lost at spa so sometimes like you
cannot completely trust the engine here
a little bit because it's if I can just
that get get rid of the heavy pieces I'm
not worse even though I'm a porn down
maybe that's opposite colored Bishop
endings it would be very Jewish if you
have played this without the heavy
pieces and he takes it five that's it's
a debt that totally dead position you
know yeah this is a risky opening but I
the the thing is I had a good
possibility here I should do this I did
not think about castling I thought about
this and thought it don't it doesn't
work every color on the cheek but I can
just Castle this is just strong an
immediate merely threatening him and
then I could Castle here to be equal
it's a bit odd that I didn't see this
one I mean it's very simple just I mean
castling must be better simply than
taking only five yeah okay thanks for
watching